a few mailbag questions before we play
football pod in america and this is a
very simple one mr juarez 13 pizza or
pasta
look i'm a pizza guy through and through
i mean pasta can go in so many different
directions but i will never say no to
pizza under any set of circumstances
there is no such thing as bad pizza any
pizza is good pizza and i probably
should be saying pasta that's probably
more of a traditional italian thing but
give me pizza any day of the week at me
then why don't you can tua take the
dolphins to a playoff win i think the
dolphins go in a playoff game
but i don't think it's going to because
because two is coming out playing like
joe burrow or justin herbert look too
wasn't horrible he wasn't bad i think
it's incomplete it's too early to make
any proclamations but it wasn't that
same oh wow holy crap that we saw from
burrow and herbert their first games
let's see what he can do this weekend
against arizona they want to see
improvement you know there's a chance
he's going to be number three out of the
three top six picks who were
quarterbacks in 2020 only one way to
find out let's see him play dolphins are
good enough to get to the playoffs and
good enough to win in the playoffs but
it may not be tua that's responsible for
it all right at pft pm posse mike
mccarthy was brought to dallas because
they had a super bowl ready roster so
why does it now seem the expectations
have changed and they're rebuilding they
weren't good before the injuries well
once dak prescott went down
the conversation changed dramatically
and it was about just salvaging and
maybe rebuilding and maybe in a
roundabout way
tanking jerry jones some of the word
salad that he offered up earlier today
on or it was yesterday on 153 the fan in
dallas suggested maybe they're thinking
about
hey if we're going to be bad anyway this
year let's see what our young players
can do and if it enhances our position
in the draft next year so be it so
they've got issues at quarterback
obviously it's going to be garrett
gilbert or cooper rush on sunday against
the steelers yes the steelers i don't
know if the winner of that competition
actually has won
anything because that guy's going to be
thrown into a blast furnace literally
against the steelers on sunday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports